i love cool lesser talked about types of
training that can help you to achieve
awesome results isometrics ticks all
those boxes and then some and in this
post i'm going to share two even lesser
known forms of isometrics that might
make a huge difference to your strength
gains
but first a quick recap
so isometrics are contractions with no
movement these come in two flavors
overcoming isometrics and yielding
isometrics the former refers to an
isometric contraction against an
immovable object trying to bend an iron
bar for instance or push down a tree
like the indian wrestler gamma
the latter kind yielding isometrics
refers to any attempt to hold a position
against resistance such as when holding
a handstand or keeping a barbell halfway
above your chest with arms bent during a
bench press
both kinds of contraction have their
benefits but it's overcoming isometrics
that will help you to increase your max
strength without necessarily increasing
muscle size
this is accomplished by increasing your
ability to recruit motor units in the
muscle in other words the nervous system
adapts to enable you to use your muscles
more totally
this also occurs during one rep max here
you use 100 of your available force to
move a weight thus training yourself to
use your muscle at maximum efficiency
but the limitation here is that during a
one rep maximum that maximum force
within the muscle only occurs for a
couple of milliseconds
at the most difficult point of the
movement
what sets an overcoming isometric apart
is that this maximum contraction is
continuous allowing for a truly max
effort over an extended period
the results speak for themselves most
old-time strongmen used some form of
overcoming isometrics modern strongman
dennis rodgers has done the same thing
to the point of exceeding even elite
athletes in his motor recruitment
as i've discussed often this was also a
key component of bruce lee's training
to utilize overcoming isometrics to
their fullest you should aim to hold
each contraction for around six seconds
you should train multiple joint angles
as the area of effect is only somewhere
between 10 to 30 degrees and you should
avoid using overcoming isometrics for
more than 10 minutes total during a
workout but now we're going to take this
concept even further with two additional
forms of isometrics
so the first is ballistic isometrics and
these are sometimes also referred to as
explosive isometrics either way you
might be thinking that they sound a
little bit contradictory
i've mentioned these before we're going
to be using them in a slightly different
way now
the idea is that you're going to try and
recruit max effort as quickly as
possible against the immovable object
exploding into that effort and thereby
potentially increasing your starting
strength and the ability to quickly
reach top power for explosive movements
you can of course wrap these out holding
the contraction for only very brief
periods or you can combine the concepts
so that you start the contraction as
explosively as possible and then hold it
for a little while after but there's
another interesting way to incorporate
ballistic isometrics too because if you
generate as much force as you can for
around six seconds measuring it with a
hand dynamic to say you will inevitably
find that it starts to taper off towards
the end as your muscle fibers fatigue
and give out if you started at 60
kilograms you might finish at a much
lower 48 kilograms but now try making
conscious effort to explosively contract
again during that contraction and you'll
find you actually do have a little force
left in the tank that you weren't using
you can bump it back up to say 55
kilograms in other words by adding a
ballistic isometric during a longer
overcoming isometric you can recruit
even more muscle fiber why because the
nervous system never allows you to
recruit 100 of your muscle fiber or even
100 of your fast twitch containing motor
units
there are always some left in reserve to
prevent injury and to conserve energy so
as you start to fatigue the motor units
you're currently using you can send a
new neural drive to recruit even more
large ones in doing so you dig deeper
recruit more strength and force more
neural adaptations so this is a great
hack for building even more strength
from isometrics
at the other end of the spectrum we have
quasi-isometrics which have much more in
common with yielding isometrics
the idea in this case is to move through
a complete range of motion as slowly as
possible potentially taking minutes to
complete a pull-up or press-up this is
much harder than it may at first sound
but it does numerous things firstly it
trains you to much more finely control
the amount of force that you're exerting
during the movement you need to recruit
and or release just the right amount of
motor units to gradually raise or lower
your body gives you much more precise
control
secondly it forces you to maintain full
concentration through the entire range
of motion and to feel that feedback from
your muscles as you do many people say
that this can help to fix technique
issues
finally it forces you to contract your
muscles continuously during the
stretched position which is well known
to elicit hypertrophy and strength gains
in short if overcoming an explosive
isometrics build brute force and power
quasi isometrics can be used to develop
finesse and precision combine both and
you can begin to control your muscles in
a way that even strength athletes rarely
manage
to get started aim for around thirty
percent of your one rep max or use body
weight to avoid injury then aim for a 30
second contraction and the same for
eccentric
obviously if you can't manage that right
away 15 seconds 20 seconds that's fine
this is very difficult and you do want
to build up to it
during the lowering phase you can choose
to use either active or passive
contractions active means that you're
engaging as much force and muscle
control as possible passive means you're
attempting to relax and use only the
necessary strength
the former is better for hypertrophy
effectively being very similar to a
negative rep or a weighted stretch the
latter can improve strength and control
and also help you to improve your
endurance and efficiency it's a
fantastic tool for rock climbers for
instance
when using these avoid extremely complex
movements that put you in a compromised
position this technique is not suitable
for deadlifts for instance a good way to
use them is at the end of a workout as a
kind of finisher you can also just do a
whole session of quasi isometrics if you
want to mix things up
these aren't the only methods for
improving muscle control and fiber
recruitment there's lots more i want to
look into in future including maxik and
the max solving method electromyo
stimulation and of course i've got tons
of other stuff on the way as usual that
digital polymath series a video on
assassin training uh the next part of
the nightwing workout so if that all
sounds good then thanks a ton for
watching and i'll speak to you next time
bye for now and by the way this video is
partly a response to a request from
viking sloth in the comments so a shout
out to him and thanks a ton for the
suggestion